Okay.
Last time we talked about the book of
revelation and I ended up by saying,
uh,
trying to place a revelation in the
context of Roman politics and the imperial
cult. Uh, clearly this author,
whoever wrote revelation,
and it is somebody named John,
all those who said,
it's not the same John who wrote
the gospels are wrote the letters.
It's not John Son of [inaudible]
is just some of the guy named John.
John was a very common name
for Jews in the first century.
So it's not uncommon that
we have a guy named John,
but don't know exactly who he is in
relation to be anybody else in early
Christianity. One of the things
that I ended, but it was by saying,
let's imagine his politics.
This is clearly an anti Roman document.
That's the one thing we
can say about it for sure.
Who would write this and why would
he write it to these seven, uh,
these seven letters to these seven
churches that we have in revelation.
One way to think about this is if this
document was written toward the last part
of the first century, uh, as a lot
of scholars think it is, he may,
this may be an, and I said,
remember his Greek is bad.
He doesn't write Greek. Well, sometimes
it's even grammatically wrong in places,
uh,
is just not bad Greek,
even though we don't have really good
Greek and most of the New Testament.
But this is the worst. How do you think
of someone who is against eating meat?
Sacrificed to idols?
Seems to think of himself as a true
Jew and the Jews who are occupying
synagogues in different parts
of Asia minor as not true,
Jews anti women as far as
their roles in the churches.
He, there's nothing we know about
this one when he calls Jezza Bell,
except that he's using this nickname
from the old testament for a whore like,
uh,
idolatrous woman Jezza Bell and labeling
some Christian woman who's a leader in
some of these, one of these churches,
he's labeling her with this terrible term.
Uh,
and I suggested maybe he's
actually writing against
the kind of Christianity we
see represented by Paul's churches,
which were right there in these places
such as ethicists and Smyrna that he's
writing too.
Because Paul's churches actually have
people in them who are fairly well off.
In some cases, they seem to be fairly
comfortable with Roman culture.
They may have their own businesses,
they have their own slaves. Uh,
there are women leaders in Paul's
churches. Paul allows that sort of thing.
As some of you have pointed
out in your papers on that, um,
and they believe it's okay to
eat meat sacrificed to idols,
which this author seems to
think is idolatrous in itself.
So I suggested that maybe this guy is
riding Rome rep revelation precisely to
attack the kind of, uh, Christianity we
see represented in Paul's on letters.
What kind of person might this be?
One way is just to imagine,
and this is pure speculation,
pure imagination.
What if this guy had come
from Palestine himself?
Maybe he lived through the Jewish war
of 70 [inaudible] 70 when the temple of
Jerusalem was destroyed and
Jerusalem was overrun by the Romans.
Thousands of Jews were taken into slavery
and taken to Rome and sold off to be
slaves. And, uh, the land was
devastated to a certain extent.
Maybe he lived through that war and
that increased his hatred of the Romans.
And he gets to western Asia Minor.
He's traveling around other parts
of the Metro, eastern Mediterranean.
He gets to western Asia Minor.
And here he doesn't see followers
of Jesus who aren't like him. Poor,
uh,
not very well educated,
perhaps hateful of the Roman empire
and sit and see themselves as being
oppressed by the Roman Empire.
He sees Christians who think that
their followers of Jesus also,
but they're fairly
comfortable in their world.
They live in a comfortable Greek
and Greco Roman urban environments.
And so he writes revelation
to try to shake them up,
to get them to hate roam
as much as he hates Rome,
to get them to be just as wary
of the imperial cult as he is.
So that's one picture definitely have of
early Christianity that we see an anti
Roman kind of politics.
The live question this week.
And the question you'll be talking about
in your discussion groups on Thursday
and Friday and some of you will be writing
papers about is what is the politics
of early Christianity in some
of the old Hollywood type days.
The idea was the,
uh,
early Christianity where it was a
movement of slaves are all completely poor
people and Rome was always going around
persecuting early Christian groups.
And there's these little bands of
early Christians huddled in dining room
somewhere huddled in, in the catacombs
and Romer huddled in caves. Well,
that's Hollywood.
The Romans actually didn't pay that much
attention to the early Christian groups
at all until much later than this.
There was no coherent persecution
attempt by the Romans against the,
uh, the Jesus movement at any time
until much later, uh, in history.
So you don't have Rome taking even
notice of most of these little house
churches, uh, founded by Paul and
other Christian missionaries, uh,
for the first several decades.
And so you had actually a variety of
ways that these people themselves related
to Rome as an empire and we,
and so we see that with revelation.
We see this heavily anti Roman view.
But remember what Paul said in Romans
13 let every person be subject to the
governing authorities.
For there is no authority except from God.
And those authorities that exist have
been instituted by God. Therefore,
whoever resists authority
resists what God has appointed.
So God has appointed the Roman governors
according to what Paul is saying here.
And those who resist will incur judgment
for rulers are not a terror to good
conduct,
but to bad government.
Roman governors are a threat only
to people who are bad, not to good.
The writer of revelation would disagree
with that completely it. This is crazy.
Do you wish to have no
fear of the authority?
Then do what is good and you'll receive
its approval for it is God's servant for
your good.
Okay?
But if you do what is wrong?
You should be afraid for the authority
does not bear the sword in vain.
It is the servant of God to
execute wrath on the wrongdoer.
So the Roman governor,
from Paul's perspective,
at least as he puts it there in Romans
13 is actually God's servant to punish
wrongdoing,
completely different view of Roman
power that we then we had in revelation.
So where do the different
documents of early Christianity?
Remember we've stressed
in the whole course.
The diversity of early Christianity is
different Christianities in the first
century. Where did the different
documents align up on their politics?
Are they revolutionary or are
they accommodating to power?
Are they pro ramen?
Are they anti Roman?
And we've already got now two seemingly
opposite positions except look over at
first Corinthians.
Now remember,
you have to have your bibles with you.
First Corinthians two verse six.
Yet among the mature we do,
we do speak wisdom.
Though it is not a wisdom of this age
or of the rulers of this age who are
doomed to perish, but we speak
God's wisdom, secret and hidden,
which God decreed before
the ages for our glory.
None of the rulers of this age
understood this for if they had,
they would not have crucified
the Lord of Glory. Now,
Paul knows that the Romans
crucified Jesus. They're almonds.
Crucifixion is not a Jewish
punishment that would be stoning.
So in the Jewish leaders wanted to
punish somebody with death and Jerusalem,
they had, they got a mob together
and they stoned the person.
Stoning was the Jewish
means of capital punishment.
Crucifixion was the Roman means of
capital punishment. Paul knows this,
so is he here talking about these
authorities who crucified Jesus?
That is the Romans.
Pilot obviously is a governor
of Judea at the time,
but pilot was simply the representative
of the Senate and the emperor.
So as Paul blaming the Senate and the
emperor for the crucifixion of Jesus here,
what does it mean by rulers? So you have
some scholars who use this text to say,
well,
even in spite of what Paul says in Romans
13 Paul doesn't have any great love in
his heart for Rome.
He still believes that they are
evil powers who crucified Jesus.
They're in the, they're in the
process of perishing as we speak,
and they'll certainly be destroyed by
God when Jesus comes back on the clouds
with his holy Angel Army.
But other scholars say, no.
The word here for ruler
are con in the Greek
could refer to superhuman and Jelic kinds
of powers we would call supernatural
powers.
So just Paula is Paul talking
here about sort of say, tannic,
angelic powers that rule the cosmos.
Because remember we've talked
about apocalyptic world view,
and one of the aspects of an apocalyptic
world view is that different countries
have these angelic forces,
these angelic leaders that are the true
power behind their government or behind
their nation.
So in Daniel,
we've got the prince of Persia is
understood as this angel who runs Persia.
So every nation has these angelic powers,
are satanic powers because of course
Satan is himself a depicted as an angel in
the UN,
in the Jewish Bible.
So is Satan just one of many kinds of
powers like this or our rulers of the
cosmos.
And is Paul actually talking about Angelic
Superhuman Powers here that crucified
Jesus rather than,
than the Romans?
Or as some scholars would do say,
and I'm in this last camp,
maybe he's talking about both.
Maybe Paul is including
the Romans in this,
these rulers who ignorantly crucified
Jesus, and so we'll be destroyed.
But maybe Paul also believes that the
Romans are themselves controlled by
superhuman, say Tannic, angelic powers.
If that's how you read
First Corinthians two,
then Paul's view of Rome
isn't quite as positive,
just straightforwardly positive as
you would get from Romans 13. Right?
So when you ask scholars,
uh, this question,
is early Christianity politically
revolutionary against Rome,
or is it politically accommodating?
You're going to get scholars
lining up on both sides of this.
Some of them say no, they read,
they read, or the Christianity is,
for the most part, revolutionary
and anti Rome. Others say, no,
it was accommodating. They were
fairly conservative and comfortable.
So this is a place we,
we assigned this topic for your papers
this week because this is actually
something where there's a live debate
that goes on among scholars themselves.
There's not one correct answer to
this question. It's complicated,
so it's a good thing for you
to look at. Of course, we,
we've already read Luke and
acts two and Luke and acts.
That author seems to present
Rome and kind of a strange,
ambiguous way.
On the one hand,
the author goes out of his way to have
Roman governor after Roman governor say
that Jesus is innocent. Paul is
innocent. This movement is innocent.
They're not revolutionary.
Paul is eventually taken to Rome,
but it's after the governor
said, well, I could release him.
I don't see anything
that this guy has done.
It's just a dispute among Jews and
yet Paul appeals to the emperor,
so he is sent to Rome in the book of acts.
But all these Roman governors declare
that Christianity is not politically
insurrectionist so that it looks like
the author is actually riding almost a
more apologetic book about the Romans
except then is that the people that
pointed out,
all of these Roman rulers come across
looking like they're rather incompetent
and powerless. They almost can't seem to
control the mobs that are around them.
They can't seem to really resist the
Jewish leaders who want to accuse Paul of
being insurrectionist,
so is wrong presented in the book of
acts and and the gospel of Luke as a good
force or a bad force
or an ambiguous force.
Now what we've got is the letters were
going to the documents we're going to
look at here
first.
Let's get second Thessalonians.
We've looked already at some of these
documents that seem clearly to be anti
Rome such as the book of revelation.
Second decile Odians is one of these
letters of Paul that some scholars believe
Paul actually wrote and other
scholars believe he did not write.
I tend to be on the camp that said
he probably did not write second
Thessalonians,
but unlike Ephesians and Colossians and
the pastoral epistles where it's much
clearer that they're written in a very
different style of Greek than Paul's
seven undisputed letters.
Second Thessalonians is actually the
Greek of second as lungs actually looks
pretty much like Paul's Greek,
so you can't throw second Thessaloniki
ins out of the authentic epistles of Paul
on the basis of the
Greek style like we can.
I think some of the other letters
that claimed to be by Paul.
Why is it that I say say, I don't think
second Thessalonians is by Paul? Well,
for one thing, this is not so important,
but we'll get to it in a minute.
He actually has a message in
second Thessalonians about
the coming of Jesus that
seems to contradict what he'd been
saying in first Thessalonians in first
Thessalonians. He says, it's coming
very soon. Get ready, don't go to sleep.
Jesus is coming back and the Paris or
will happen is all going to happen very
soon. And he says, no, we don't
know exactly when it's gonna happen,
but it's going to happen very soon.
In Second Thessalonians, as we'll see,
he actually says, no, no, no,
no. Don't quit work or anything.
Don't quit your day job because some of
the people and desolate Annika according
to this author seem to have quit their
jobs because they're ready for Jesus to
come back so soon. He says, no,
no, you should still be working.
There is going to be a few things that'll
happen first before the end comes and
then he lays out a timeline of
what he's expecting to happen.
And I'm going to walk you through
that timeline in a minute.
So some scholars who said what second
Thessalonians teaches about the end time
and the coming back of Jesus differs
enough from what Paul had actually said
about it in first Thessalonians,
that it might be written by a different
person at a different time in a
different situation.
That's one argument.
I think the more convincing argument to
me is if you take the beginning of first
Thessalonians,
I mean the beginning of
second Thessalonians and the
end of second Thessalonians
and you put them side by side
with parts of first Thessalonians,
they look very, very much
alike. Now wait a minute,
they look alike.
So that means they're not by Paul.
This is what I'm thinking
when you, if, if I'm,
if Paul is going to sit down
and write another letter,
the second [inaudible] is he going to do
so with the copy of first Thessalonians
in front of him?
Is he going to do so even recalling the
same words and phrases that he used in
the previous letter? I don't
think so. In other words,
I think second testimonials in certain
parts of it looks suspiciously too much
like first Thessalonians
to be an authentic leader
by Paul because when people
write another letter,
they use different words they so that
you don't sit down and basically repeat
words and phrases and things
from your previous letter.
So that made the one place
where you don't sign.
Find those words and phrases being the
same is precisely in the second chapter
of Second Thessalonians,
that middle part where this author is
teaching a different timeline for the end
time than first Thessalonians head.
So in my mind I'm thinking, okay,
if you want to ride a pseudonymous
letter and claim to be by Paul,
how do you make it convincing? Well, if
you knew first Thessalonians is a letter,
you might actually take that as a model
and read for assessment is carefully and
imitate the style and
imitate even what's said.
But then you stick in the second chapter
of Second Thessalonians where you give
your own timeline for what
you think is going to happen.
So that's why I think
it's probably not by Paul,
but scholars kind of divide up on second
Thessalonians and a lot of different
ways with many scholars,
even critical scholars who don't believe
Paul wrote all the letters that are in
his name in the New Testament and they'll
say they still think Paul did right?
Second vessel onions. But now what's
the goal of writing? And here's what,
let's look at this chapter two,
the first 12 verses of chapter two.
Now read along with me so you'll know
I'm not lying to you because every time I
get a chance I like to lie to students,
lead them astray
as to the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ
and are being gathered together to him.
We beg you brothers. Again, it doesn't
say sisters in the original Greek,
not to be quickly shaken in mind or alarm,
either by spirit or by word or by letter,
as though from us to the effect that
the day of the Lord is already here.
So he's mentioning there may have been
a letter circulated in Paul's name
claiming that the resurrection
has already happened.
The day of the Lord has already come.
So there's a reference to notice how
if this letter is synonymous as I claim
there's a reference to a pseudonymous
letter in the pseudonymous letter.
That's actually not unusual
in the ancient world.
Sometimes if you're riding a pseudonymous
letter, you'll put a reference, say,
well now some people been circulating
synonymous letters by me and I condemn
them for it. Of course it's in a letter.
That probably itself is pseudonymous.
That's irony, irony. We see in
some of these ancient letters,
let no one deceive you in any way
for that day will not come unless the
rebellion comes first and the
lawless one is revealed. Okay.
The lawless one,
what's the talking about here?
The one destined for destruction.
He opposes and exalts himself above every
so called God or object of worship so
that he takes his seat in the temple
of God, declaring himself to be God.
So this is something like another sort
of antichrist figure that we've seen in
the book of Daniel.
Uh,
Jesus in his own little apocalypse in
mark 13 other places talks about the
abomination of desolation
being set up in the temple. Uh,
so this author is saying this person
is going to call himself God and set
himself up in the temple in Jerusalem.
Do you not remember that I told you these
things when I was still with you and
you know what is now restraining him so
that he may be revealed when his time
comes. Okay? Now the risk,
the thing restraining him comes from
one Greek word cut tech on and it means
something holding back or something
holding, holding back something.
And we can't tell necessarily here
whether this is talking about a thing,
a power or a person.
Is there a person who's keeping this
guy back in the wings who's not letting
this a divine self promoter settings
and set himself up in Jerusalem
for the mystery of lawlessness
is already at work,
but only until the one who
now restrains is removed. Ah,
so this restraining force,
our risk training thing are restraining
person is at some point going to be
removed from the geographic,
from the political scene,
and then this other
characters is going to come in
and then the lawless one will be revealed.
Yeah.
Whom the Lord Jesus will destroy with
the breadth of his mouth annihilating him
by the manifestation of his coming.
The coming of the lawless one is apparent
in the working of Satan who uses all
power signs,
lying wonders,
every kind of wicked deception for those
who are perishing because they refuse
to love the truth and soul be saved.
For this reason,
God sends them a powerful delusion.
Leading them to believe what is false
so that all who have not believed the
truth but took pleasure in
unrighteousness will be condemned.
What's going on here?
Well,
there's some extent your
guess is as good as mine,
except that I know a bit more about
ancient Jewish apocalyptic and so I have a
few resources to draw on.
For one thing though,
I think what's going on here is this
author is referring to some kind of
antichrist figure.
He doesn't use the term here,
but he's clearly saying this is someone
who's setting himself up as as divine
has god.
He's going to take a seat in the temple
in Jerusalem and he's going to proclaim
himself to be God, or perhaps he's also
referring to a messianic pretender.
Maybe he's thinking that
this will be another messiah,
a false messiah of sorts.
That is the anti Christ.
If that's true, then what was he imagined
going on? I think what he's doing,
and this is my speculation,
I think he's actually imagining
a Jewish false messiah,
this cert,
somewhere hidden.
He knows not where there's some guy
somewhere in Palestine or someplace else
who's hiding in the wings, waiting
for the moment when he can come out,
declare himself as the Messiah and enter
the Jerusalem temple and set himself up
as the Divine Messiah figure.
If so,
what's keeping him from doing it now?
Well,
maybe it's just some supernatural force.
Maybe it's even God.
Maybe as God has just decided it's
not yet time for this to happen.
But what if the thing that's keeping
them from doing it now is precisely the
Romans.
In other words,
the force that's keeping any Jewish
Messiah figure down now would be the Roman
empire. They're not allowing kings.
No. Look what they did with Jesus.
They also executed other, uh,
Messiah figures in the first century.
The author therefore sees the Roman
emperor at work and the Roman Empire,
and that's the thing,
restraining this false messiah
from setting up shop in Jerusalem,
but he says that's going to be taken away.
How's that going to happen?
Again, we don't know. But in my mind,
it's the idea that somehow
the Roman emperor is going
to be moved out of the way
by God when the time comes
for this all to happen.
And then there's Jewish Messiah was set
himself up and then Jesus will come in,
destroy the false messiah,
and that's when we'll have the setting
up of the real kingdom of God. Now,
as I said,
that's speculation,
but what I'm doing is saying what kind
of scenario is he possibly imagining?
But the reason I do this little scenario
is because what would be this guy's
view of Rome and the relationship
between the Christian movement,
the Jesus Movement and Rome? Well,
he, if my little scenarios right,
he doesn't see Rome as simply an
a whole heartedly negative thing.
Rome actually has a purpose in God's plan.
Rome's purpose is to keep back this
false Jewish Messiah from appearing.
And then when that purpose has done, God
will remove the Roman Empire from being,
uh, uh, political, uh, geopolitical force.
And then the beginning,
the real beginning of the
end time schedule will kick
into gear and Jesus will
come through,
destroy this lawless one,
the one set of false messiah also
destroy the Romans preps and set up the
Kingdom of God. But what that
does is that gives us another,
another look at what an author
may have conceived Rome to be.
And it's not nearly as negative
as the revelation offer author.
It may not also be completely positive
either because he still sees Rome
apparently is being destroyed in the end.
So second Thessalonians though therefore
looks like a case where someone's
writing a letter in Paul's name precisely
to counter the idea that Jesus is
coming back tomorrow.
And because he believes you have to
have a certain number of things that are
going to happen, it's still is
fairly soon in the future. He's not,
he's not expecting a thousand
years or anything like that,
but he's seems to believe that there's
gonna be a timeline of geopolitical
events that take place before Jesus
comes back. So that second Thessalonians,
any questions,
comments or outburst about
that before I move on?
Yes sir.
Is it possible that to give it the
cult of the Roman emperor or here
that he might be referring
to the Roman emperor here?
Uh, it could be, uh, in fact,
uh, that that's possibly the way
some things set up. But the thing,
the reason I don't think
it's the Roman emperor,
here's because he talks
about this character as if
he's hidden for the moment.
It's a mystery and the won't,
he's not revealed the Roman emperor.
You could have never said here was not,
was not revealed.
The Roman emperor was visible everywhere
you looked in the Mediterranean.
It's time, statues, inscriptions, temples.
So I think he's probably not talking
to the Roman emperor as the lawless one
that cause the Roman emperor
wasn't hidden at the time.
Okay.
Any other questions? Okay. Now though,
let's look at first Peter.
So we're going to another little text
that asking again the same question.
What is the politics of the
early Christian movement?
The early Jesus Movement?
First Peter, by most of us scholars, we
don't believe Peter Actually wrote it.
Um, the reasons are again, numerous.
And notice,
this is not an anonymous letter like a,
the letters of John are that
don't claim to be written by John.
This one actually claims to be written by
Peter the Apostle as does second Peter.
Why do we think Peter the actual apostle
didn't write it well? For one thing,
Peter was even as, uh, the
new testament several times,
lets us know an illiterate fishermen,
he probably couldn't read or write
if he could read or write. He,
it's almost certain that he couldn't
read or write Greek at the level of Greek
that this letter is written.
There are other things in the letter
that make us think that it looks like a
Christianity in a little bit later
stage than the very primitive area of
Christianity. The development
of doctrine, the development of,
of the notions of Peter himself.
Uh,
the idea that that certainly the theology
of the letter seemed to look later
than the most primitive
time of early Christianity.
But most of us would just say simply on
the basis of the language itself. Uh,
we don't believe the Peter,
the actual apostle wrote this letter.
So look what he's, he's, he's
right. He says, he says, Peter,
an apostle of Jesus Christ to the exiles
of the dispersion in punches, Galicia,
Kappa Dosha, Asia and Bithynia.
So again, he's writing to,
he calls them exiles of the dispersion
so that some people might think, well,
these talking to Jews then the,
the disperse Jews,
but he clearly including
gentile Christians in this
too. So he's talking about,
uh, followers of Jesus who
live in all these different,
this different geographical area.
And again,
this is sort of what we would now
call Turkey, the area of Turkey,
both Asia minor, which proper was
just the western side of Turkey,
but pretty much all that
area of that occupies Turkey.
Now he calls them exiles though.
And I don't think he's talking about
this in an actual political sense.
He spiritualizing the notion
that followers of Jesus
are exiles in our world.
We don't belong here. He
says. So he says also,
um,
one 17,
if you invoke his father,
the one who judges all people impartially
according to these live in reverent
fear during the time of your exile.
Again,
followers of Jesus are exiles to 11.
Beloved,
I urge you as aliens and exiles to
abstain from the desires of the flesh,
that wage war against the soul.
These are great terms that would have
meant in the ancient context precisely
what illegal alien means.
And I'm co contemporary American context.
You're here illegally. So all the
followers of Jesus, according to a rider,
live in the Roman Empire as illegal
aliens basically are not illegal aliens,
but definitely is aliens.
Maybe they're illegal aliens,
but they don't really belong.
So he also said,
he's talking not just to Jews.
He says in one 18,
you know that you were ransomed from
the futile ways inherited from your
ancestors, not with perishable
things like silver and gold,
with the precious body of
Christ's blood of Christ.
So the ancestors referring here,
he's clearly from to gentiles who have
come into the church, uh, as gentiles,
and then now occupy their
role, uh, as people,
as part of this alien people to now,
what's this guy's politics?
Look at two 13
for the Lord's sake, except the
authority of every human institution.
Uh,
now we're pretty clear that the authority
here is not at least just referring to
angelic type supernatural authorities,
but he's referring to the human rulers,
whether of the impo emperor as supreme
or of governors as sent by him to punish
those who do wrong and to praise
those who do. Right? Of course,
the governors of the different parts of
the Roman empire were appointed either
by the Senate or by the emperor himself.
This author's not too neat about,
uh,
the actual politics of the first century.
So He seems to believe that all go rub
governors are appointed by the emperor,
which was in fact not the case,
but some of them weren't.
Many of them are appointed by the Senate.
He doesn't care about
those kinds of niceties.
For it is God's will that by doing right,
you should silence the ignorance of the
foolish as servants of God live as free
people. Yet do not use your freedom
as a pretext for evil. Honor everyone.
Love the family of believers.
Fear God. Honor the emperor.
Can you imagine the author of
revelation saying that he could not,
it would have broken his jaw to say,
honor the emperor.
He also doesn't seem to have a whole lot
of love for just people in general. The,
the book of revelation seems to have a
lot of loyalty for the people who are in
the group,
but there seems to be a lot of despising
for pretty much anybody outside the
group.
So that's the political
conservatism of first Peter.
He's writing a letter to followers of
Jesus who live throughout the area of
Turkey. He's trying to get them to see
that they don't really belong to Rome.
They're not Romans, he doesn't,
doesn't address them as Romans.
They don't really belong to the
political situations they're living in.
They should see themselves as aliens,
as exiles and yet they're still see
themselves as properly subservient,
honorable,
well behaved exiles in a Roman context.
And so that plays itself out
also in some of the other, uh,
social justice issues in this,
in the politics. Look at two 18,
right where we stopped after. He
says, honor the emperor slaves,
except the authority of your
masters with all deference,
not only those who are kind and gentle,
but also those who are harsh for it as a
credit to you. If B, being aware of God,
you're endure pain while
suffering unjustly.
If you endure when you are beaten
for doing wrong, what credit is that?
If you endure, when you do write and
suffer for it, you have God's approval.
This is ideologically very problematic.
Telling slaves,
you know, just submit. And
if you're being beaten,
don't blame your master for beating
you. Just endure it. I mean,
if you do wrong and your master beats you,
then you deserve to get beaten,
but you should endure it even when you
get beaten for things you don't deserve.
Talk about the opiate of the masses.
This is precisely the kind of religion
that classical Marxism critiques or
religion that exists to keep the slaves,
the slave, to keep the poor poor,
to keep the downtrodden,
downtrodden.
So part of the honoring of the emperor
is to teach slaves just to submit.
And if you can't enjoy it when you're
being beaten, at least put up with it.
Look at, uh, three,
one through seven wives in the same way
except the authority of your husbands.
My mom used to always hate it when
that read out these passages in church,
we'd have a very loud
discussion of such patches.
It's over Sunday dinner then after
this wives in the same way except the
authority of your husbands. So that even
if some of them do not obey the word,
they may be won over without a word
by their wives conduct. She used to.
Some of these women are followers of Jesus
and their husbands are not Christians.
They should still obey them.
Though he says he doesn't allow women
to use their Christian allegiance,
uh,
and there the Lordship of Christ over
them to get out from under the Lordship of
their husbands.
Yeah.
Do not adorn yourself outwardly
by braiding your hair,
by wearing gold ornaments
are fine clothing. Rather,
let your adornment be the inner self
with the lasting beauty of a gentle and
quiet spirit,
which is very precious in God's sight.
My mom especially hated that
gentle and quiet spirit part.
She had no intentions of being
a very gentle and quiet spirit.
It wasn't this way long ago.
Did the holy women who hoped in God used
to adorn themselves by accepting the
authority of their husbands.
And he goes on like that
and they look at five five
chapter five verse five.
In the same way you who are younger
must accept the authority of elders.
And all of you must clothe yourselves
with humility in the dealings with one
another. For God opposes the proud,
but gives grace to the humble.
So in all of this stuff,
this author is basically telling people,
stay in your place. No
revolution, no rebellion.
Don't even resent the people who are
over you and have authority over you.
So this is quite clearly political,
quieting them
political accommodation.
Uh,
and one of the reasons he's doing this
as scholars appointed is that he seems to
believe that Christians can help their
reputation if they don't rock the boat.
So you get versus like this to 12,
conduct yourselves honorably among the
gentiles. Now notice he's, these are some,
these are converted gentiles themselves,
but he doesn't call them gentiles because
the gentiles is still now a term for
those people outside the body of Christ,
outside of Christianity,
conduct yourselves honorably among the
gentiles so that though they malign you
as evil doers,
they may see your honorable deeds and
glorify God when he comes to judge.
And in chapter three verse 15
okay,
in your heart,
sanctify Christ as Lord.
Always be ready to make your defense
to anyone who demands from you and
accounting for the hope that is in you,
yet with gentleness and reverence.
So he's basically very conservative
in his politics and his ideology.
For one reason,
he wants these groups of followers of
Jesus not to be disrespected by outsiders.
He wants them to develop a good reputation
so that they can't be persecuted so
that they can't be opposed
by local authorities.
So here we have a clear case of a totally
different ideological take on early
Christianity, but it's still
apocalyptic. This is what's interesting.
He's still this, hi, hi. This
other hasn't thrown away.
The Christian apocalyptic that we saw
working so much in revelation to be anti
Roman. He still has it. You
can see places. He says in
chapter four, verse seven,
the end of all things is near. Well,
that's apocalyptic. Cism the end is near.
Therefore, be serious and discipline
yourself for the sake of your prayers. Uh,
in four 12,
beloved,
do not be surprised by the fiery ordeal
that is taking place you to test you as
though something strange were happening
to you. So any suffering that you have,
he says chocolate up to the suffering
that comes with the apocalyptic fire.
This is testing you. So
again, just endure it.
And 17 for the time has come for judgment
to begin with the household of God.
If it begins with us,
what will be the end for those
who do not obey the gospel of God?
So he does believe that the people who
are persecuting them now are dissing them.
Now, I'm not so sure that sometimes it
was astrical physical persecution in these
communities were enduring. He may just
believe that they're being disrespected,
that they're being discriminated
against in some way.
But what his solution to this is for
them not to rock the boat, not to rebel,
not to fight back, but actually to just
be good boys and girls. Be Submissive.
Slaves, be submissive women to your
husbands. And then, uh, if possible,
people will see your submission
and that'll make them
respect the message of the
Gospel. If not, those
people will be destroyed.
But we have to into our own punishment
and serving. Now also the apocalyptic,
they apocalyptic material here there
serves a different purpose than it did in
revelation and some other
Christian and Jewish texts.
It's not particularly there to
make you to explain your suffering.
It's just there to be endured.
It's just there because it's part of
the message of early Christianity.
So it doesn't really help fight against
injustice in any way as you might be
able to see it doing other texts. Now,
how does this happen in second, Peter,
we'll just look at this briefly
because we're almost out of time,
but I show you one more thing.
I believe second Peter was
written by someone else,
not Peter again for some
of the same reasons,
but I also believe it was not written
by the same person who wrote first Peter
because it's rather different.
In fact,
I believe Second Peter was written
sometime in the second century,
maybe even decades after
the letters of Paul and,
and the book of revelation
and these others were written.
And it seems to me to show a different
stage in the development of Christianity,
Christianity.
Now it looks different in the second
century than it did in the first century.
And I'll walk you through this and
show why I say that and how it works.
First look at second Peter Three two.
Well,
we'll start reading at the beginning
of chapter three. This is now beloved.
The second letter I'm writing to you.
Ah,
so he seems to know about the existence
of the first letter of Peter in them.
I'm trying to arouse your
sincere intention by reminding
you so that you should
remember the words spoken in the past
by the holy prophets and the commandment
of the Lord and Savior
spoken through your apostles.
So this is already something
like a post epistolic letter.
He's hearkening back to the beginning
of the Christian movement when they were
prophets and apostles,
even though he's setting himself up
as Peter the Apostle in the letter,
the tone of the letter makes it sound
like the apostolic era is somewhere in the
past for, for this guy's a version
of Christianity for his community.
So we read second Peter is actually a
really good example of post epistolic new
testament writing. He also has
references to the gospels themselves.
Look at one 17.
Uh,
I'll start reading at one 16
for we did not follow cleverly,
cleverly devised myths when we made
known to you the power and coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ. But we had
been eyewitnesses of his majesty,
for he had received for he received
honor and glory from God the father.
When that voice was conveyed to him by
the majestic glory saying, this is my son,
my beloved,
with whom I am well pleased.
We ourselves heard this
voice come from heaven.
When we were with him on the Holy
Mountain, what is he referring to?
What's the event exactly? The
transfiguration. He's red, his gospels,
at least one of them.
And he's hearkening back to the story
of the transfiguration of Jesus on the
mountain with Moses and Elijah there.
And of course who were the apostles?
The disciples were with Jesus at the
time, Peter and, and was one of them.
There were three of them.
So Peter was there and he's recalling
that scene from the gospels.
So there's reference to Gospel traditions
here and maybe even he's actually read
some written gospels that
we have in our text. Uh,
he also says because something
like a reference to first Peter is,
I already said that my, when he says
I've already written to you once,
that could be a reference to first Peter.
And then he talks about Paul's letters.
So he knows Paul's letters.
Three 15 wait, is that right?
Yep. Sorry, we get three
14. Therefore beloved,
while you are waiting for these things,
strive to be found by him at peace,
without spot or blemish and regard
the patients of our Lord as salvation.
So also our brother Paul wrote to you
according to the wisdom given him.
Speaking of this,
as he does in all his letters,
there are some things in
them hard to understand,
which are the ignorant and unstable
twist to their own destruction as they do
the other scriptures, you therefore
beloved. So he goes on to admonish them,
but notice what he's doing. He actually
calls Paul's letters scripture.
Now, Paul, when he was
writing his letters,
he thought he was riding
authoritative letters,
but there were authoritative because
he was an apostle who had founded the
churches. Most of the time
he was writing to churches.
He himself found it so he felt like he
had authority over these churches to
write authoritative letters, but Paul
didn't think he was writing scripture.
When Paul talks about
scripture in his letters,
he's talking about Jewish scripture,
the Greek translation of the Hebrew Bible.
This guy though is far enough removed
from Paul's own day that he can actually
refer to Paul's letters as themselves.
Part of scripture.
That's one of the things we run.
The reason we think this
took a while to develop.
You just don't have in early Christianity
the automatic acceptance of Paul's
occasional letters because they were
real letters written to real situations.
Being elevated now to the status
of holy writing scripture.
This author is living now in a post
epistolic age in a post Pauline age and
he's, he obviously he's is
probably by this time, they don't,
they don't have a new testament yet,
but probably about this time,
he's already familiar with
maybe a collection of Paul's
letters that are being
circulated as scripture among
different churches in Asia Minor.
He also may,
as I said,
be be familiar with some gospels that
are being circulated as off authoritative
texts in early Christianity.
So he's clearly living in
a later time. Like I said,
maybe in the second century
when these things have happened.
And then one last thing that is
interesting to, to talk about, uh,
what keep your finger there in second
Peter, but we're going to look at Jude.
So flip over to Jude,
which is right before revelation.
Okay.
Jude is a short little letter.
Jude 14.
Okay.
It was also about these,
he's talking about Tom Evil
angels are angels of some sort.
That Enoch member Enoch is
that character in the very,
very early part of genesis who was
only a few generations from Adam.
But there were apocalypses written and
Enoch's name and published just in the
last century or so before
this, that, uh, two sec,
two or three centuries before
this. So we have different, uh,
different documents called the
apocalypse of Enoch or the revelation of
[inaudible] you knock itself,
Enoch in the seventh generation
from Adam prophesied saying,
see the Lord is coming with 10 thousands
of his holy ones to execute judgment on
all and to convict every one of the
deeds of ungodliness that they have
committed in such an ungodly way and
of all the harsh things that ungodly
sinners have spoken against.
Yeah.
So notice what he's doing. He's
quoting, he knock it literature,
which isn't in our Bible as if it is also
true prophecy in scripture from Enoch.
Okay? Now that's what Jude does. It's not,
it's important because he's
having a debate about angels.
But now look over at second Peter Two 10
is this right?
Yes.
I'm not going to read all of
this, but um, if you look at,
if you read second Peter
Two Verses 10 through 22,
you have a bunch of material that
second Peter is getting out of Jude.
In other words,
second Peter,
they're all three second Peter
doesn't only know the letters of Paul,
he knows Jude also and he's using Jude
as a source and he copied some of that
out. But what's interesting enough,
he takes out the quotation from Enoch.
He doesn't have that. And there was, he
takes Jude as a good Christian source,
but he takes out the stuff he found
in Jude that he doesn't consider good
Christian material and
Christian scripture.
So he edits out of Jude stuff that by
that time he believes is not really part
of Christian scripture.
What again,
what this shows us is that their author
of second Peter is living in a time when
we actually see the beginning of
Christian scripture coming about.
This is a very different time from the
epistolic period when they were just
writing letters,
occasional letters for different purposes,
not having any idea that they were
creating a new testament themselves.
This author is not living in the time
by which we have a new testament that'll
take another few centuries to come about.
As I talked about the very first lecture
when I talked about Canon development,
that's going to happen,
but he's certainly living in a time
that's between the epistolic period when
everything is much more chaotic and
there's not any Christian scripture.
And now you do have Christian scripture
scripture on its way to becoming its own
canon. So Ha. So this isn't
a post epistolic period.
So the last thing is what
does the apocalyptic do here?
Look at three verse three Second Peter
Three verse three because there is
apocalyptic here also. First,
you must understand this,
that in the last days scoffers will come
scoffing and indulging their own lusts
and saying, where is the promise of his
coming for? Ever since our ancestors died,
all things continue as they were
from the beginning of creation.
Notice that's gotta be posts.
Peter Peter in his own time
would never have talked about.
The beginning of the Jesus
movement is happening way,
way in there with our ancestors,
right?
They deliberately ignore this
fact that by the word of God,
the heavens existed long ago and an earth
was formed out of water and by means
of water through which the world of
that time was diluted with water and
perished by the same word.
The present heavens and earth
had been reserved for fire,
had been kept until the day of judgment
and destruction of the goddess.
So he believes this end is coming,
this end of fire,
the destruction of the current world,
but do not ignore this one fact,
beloved that with the Lord,
one day is like a thousand years and
a thousand years are like one day.
The Lord is not slow about his
promise as some think of slowness,
but is patient with you not wanting any
to perish but all to come to repentance.
But the day of the Lord will come like
a thief and then the heavens will pass
away with a loud noise.
The elements will be dissolved with fire
and the earth and everything that is
done on it will be disclosed so that
he does have an apocalyptic scenario,
but what does it do for him?
Nothing.
It's just something that's part of
Christian doctrine that he's passing on.
He's not,
there's no franticness here.
There's no idea that it's going
to happen right now. In fact,
he says it could happen
in a thousand years.
We're no longer with this letter in a
kind of Christianity that has apocalyptic
fervor to it.
We're in a kind of Christianity that
is starting to have its own Christian
scripture, this fairly
conservative, again,
politically that you don't see a lot of
stuff against Rome in that sort of thing,
and the function of the apocalyptic
apocalyptic autism here is simply us.
Just something you believe if you're a
Christian. Again, it's another example.
Apocalyptic is a political ideology,
but what kind of politics it teaches in
the early times of Christianity can very
apocalyptic,
can be something that strengthens you
against Roman oppression that labels Rome
for you as a whore and
Jessebelle and a monster.
Or it can teach you to be quiet
and go about your business.
So one of the things you're going to
be talking about today and your in your
sections is which kinds of texts and
early Christianity that we've looked at
function what way politically
and apocalyptic is one of
those political kinds of
forces in early Christianity,
although certainly not the only one.
You're supposed to look at these texts
and say what politics is assumed by these
texts.
So you next week.